[Music]
and now I shall awaken her with true
love's kiss name and wanna kissing of
sleeping women is a federal offense but
she's my one true love
Joe Olivia welcome my true love's kiss
tell it to the judge you creep
watch the crown
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that turns your favorite
bedtime stories into nightmare fuel
today we're diving back into the Shrek
franchise because well honestly I wanted
to do something on an animated movie but
didn't really feel like writing another
prediction theory for frozen - and Shrek
is well he's always relevant and I've
been thinking about the franchise a lot
thanks in large part to the excellent
analysis videos on the channel Schaefer
Ellis Productions which if you've never
heard of does awesome videos analyzing
all sorts of classic animated movies but
more on him and his work later so what
else is there to say about Trek nearly
20 years after it was first released
well how about we finally put a
definitive solution behind the
mysterious origins of its most iconic
character I mean as most of you know the
Shrek universe is chock full of fairy
tale and Nursery Rhyme characters who
when the movie begins are getting
rounded up and turned in for a reward
all the big name fairytale characters
are their Seven Dwarves the three bears
Tinkerbell no key Oh a talking donkey
three blind mice but in the words of
Sesame Street but one of these things
just doesn't belong here a talking
donkey have you ever really stopped to
think about that I mean all these other
fairy tale characters are super famous
and easily recognizable even the generic
characters like witches and ogres and
princesses trapped in towers are tropes
from countless other fairy tales but a
talking donkey where is he from that my
loyal theorists is the question that we
explore today what is the origin of
Shrek donkey because I think I have an
answer one that is provable beyond a
reasonable doubt and let's just say that
the conclusion to this one is not giving
us a happy ever after if you search
through fairy tale Lord there's really
only one famous talking donkey to note
the titular character in the Brothers
Grimm fairy tale the donkey it's not one
that most people know but basically it
goes a little something like this
a rich king and queen are upset that
they can't have a son but then one day
God blesses the couple and she suddenly
gives birth to a donkey
she wants to kill it because you know
don't
baby but the King refuses and so the
couple raise it as their son so we have
ourselves a donkey who learns to speak
and have manners
he even teaches himself how to play
music and this is starting to sound a
lot like our donkey from Shrek right he
speaks English he sings all the time he
could have decent enough table manners
when he needs to and is one of the few
fairytale characters who knows the way
to lord farquaad's castle suggesting a
possible royal backstory who knows where
this Farquaad guy is oh I do I'm
hilarious does anyone else that's not
all there's one really suspicious quote
from the fairy tale that seems to lock
this in as our donkey quote the young
lordling once went out walking full of
thought and came to a well he looked
into it and in the mirror clear water
saw his donkey's form
he was so distressed about it that he
went out into the wide world and only
took with him one faithful companion one
faithful travelling companion it's an
especially weird detail for this fairy
tale to include because that is all we
ever hear about this other mysterious
character but using context please we
can clearly identify this as someone
who's a loner is also comfortable
travelling with a donkey so that pretty
much points to someone like Shrek right
this is absolutely the origin story for
our talking donkey isn't it it would be
until you get to the big twist at the
end of the story you see the donkey and
his companion go to another Kingdom and
make friends with the king who marries
his daughter off to the donkey because
you know the donkey is depressed you
know times were different back then okay
anyway just as the donkey and his bride
are about to you know celebrate their
marriage night the donkey takes his skin
off to reveal himself to be a real boy
King doesn't believe it so the next
night he sneaks into his daughter's room
and watches the proceedings there's a
lot of reasons you weren't told this one
at story time at night or reasons why
people don't choose to adapt Grimm's
fairy tales accurately anyway suffice it
to say the king is impressed with what
he sees all the old people in the story
die and the donkey gets himself a wife
and two kingdoms but you can start to
see our problem as far as this theory is
concerned right the donkey in the fairy
tale isn't
real donkey it's just a human disguised
inside of a donkey's skin but one glance
at donkey and dragons offspring and
Shrek the third is all the proof we need
that Shrek's donkey is a hundred percent
donkey and zero percent human those are
drawn keys and dongjun's no doubt about
it
so the grimms donkey out of the picture
we're back at square one which honestly
kind of sucks because that would have
been the best title and thumbnail ever
which means a return to the drawing
board so we know donkey is a fairytale
character otherwise he wouldn't be
getting rounded up with all the others
or worth any sort of reward
so is he one just made up for the
purposes of these movies or could there
be another explanation for what's really
going on here well two years ago in a
now-deleted reddit post a user named
year me vee proposed a different
possibility that donkey did indeed hail
from a fairy tale in fact one that is
far more popular than Grimm's the donkey
ever was good donkey be one of the
kidnapped boys from Tokyo is it possible
that donkey started as a human child one
stolen off of the street and shipped off
to Pleasure Island where he like so many
others before him would transform into a
donkey and eventually be sold off into
slavery
no admittedly that's a pretty dark
backstory for a main character in a PG
rated franchise about an ogre who farts
a bunch but it would help explain why in
a movie full of celebrity cameos from
history's most iconic fairy tales we
would spend so much time with an
otherwise out-of-place talking donkey
and the rationale here doesn't just boil
down to throwing up our arms and saying
well they're practically the only other
fairytale donkeys of note so he must be
one of them the clues pointing towards a
Shrek Pinocchio crossover are ogres are
like onions Oh curse have layers onions
have layers you get it so let's start
peeling them back first let's look at
what few details we can actually learn
about donkey's backstory based on some
of the things he says throughout the
movies he says this in Shrek the third
registan to feel nauseous for memories
of wedgies and swirlies as Puss in Boots
points out moments later donkeys don't
wear clothes so this would suggest that
donkey was a human at some point in his
life
when he was a child how else would he
have been given a wedgie donkeys don't
wear clothes but human children
absolutely do or at least they're
supposed to know screaming naked babies
around here later on and that's a movie
donkey and puss swap bodies and we get
ourselves this short conversation but
that we're maybe much played by the
finest
oh you'll learn to control that this
seems to suggest that donkey learned to
talk as a donkey later in life I mean
after all who can remember what it's
like learning to talk as a baby
if donkey was a school-age boy who got
himself turned into a donkey and
Pleasure Island however he would
remember how hard it was to talk
normally following his transformation
and how when it first happened his
normal patterns of speech started to get
interrupted by uncontrollable donkey
Bray's and wouldn't you know it that's
not just me speculating here it's
exactly what we see happen in Pinocchio
when we watch lamp-wick transform on
Pleasure Island we see two key things
one that he is indeed able to continue
speaking like a human despite being
fully transformed into a donkey and to
his normal speech starts to get
interrupted with donkey noises in fact
based on the scenes we know one
additional detail here boys who are
transformed into donkeys but still able
to talk fluently are sent back to
Pleasure Island for a little bit longer
until they fully lose that ability this
scene also demonstrates another key
feature of how the donkeys get treated
on Pleasure Island they're allowed to
keep their clothes until they're ready
to be sold off to the salt mines here we
see a child who's gone full donkey gets
stripped of his clothes by the coachman
and sent to the crate where as Alexander
our boy from earlier is allowed to stay
dressed now this is important because
donkey in Shrek clearly has memories of
being both a donkey and wearing clothes
this donkeys still allowed to wear
clothes detail not only opens up the
possibility of him getting called donkey
dumpy drawers we know that Pleasure
Island is specifically full of bullies
the boys are all trapped there because
they misbehave
so another half turned a child making
fun of donkey for being scared and
soiling his donkey drawers totally
within the realm of possibility here and
lastly it probably goes without saying
but it's definitely worth pointing out
it's clearly established that both
Pinocchio and Shrek share the same
universe heck the first time we see
donkey he's standing behind Pinocchio in
line
could this be DreamWorks his way of
slyly suggesting that the two characters
are linked maybe maybe not but if
nothing else it verifies that trek pulls
from the Pinocchio lore so it would make
perfect sense for a Pleasure Island
donkey to be walking around somewhere in
this world so the Pleasure Island Theory
gives us a source for donkeys who wear
clothes used to be human and have
learned to talk as donkeys all of which
line up with a few small details that
donkeys let slip about his own pass
throughout these movies but I just wish
that there was something more like one
final clinching piece of evidence
something that's a little less lore
based and a little bit more I don't know
design based scientific brain blast I
got it look at their species donkey
appears to be the exact same breed of
donkey as the boys turned donkey enoki
oh look at this in Pinocchio it seems
like the Pleasure Island boys turn into
one of two types of donkeys either all
brown or all grey no colour at the tips
of the ears a lighter color along their
stomach and a little tuft of either
black or brown hair on their head and
down into their neck and now look at
donkey in Shrek same design great tall
ears with no colour at the tips a
lighter color of grey along his stomach
and a little tuft of black hair on his
head neck this seems really important to
point out because there are over a
hundred and forty different donkey
breeds and these breeds all have very
different hair lengths very different
hair colors and very distinct markings
till the fact that donkey is matching up
to the exact type that we see coming out
of Pleasure Island feels like The
Smoking Gun that we were missing before
so at this point I have little choice
but to stamp this theory as matpat
certified fresh'
really considering all this evidence how
could donkey not be a now grown boy from
Pleasure Island the theory has an answer
for pretty much everything we know about
the character we've established one that
it make him one of the very few famous
fairytale donkeys to that he was once
human three wore clothes as a donkey
four learned to control his brain but
can still talk in English five was
bullied in donkey form six comes from a
lore that also exists in Shrek and seven
just so happens to be the exact species
of donkey coming out of Pleasure Island
there is simply no other fairy tale or
nursery rhyme out there that covers the
spread the way the Pleasure Island
Theory does not even close but if this
is true which it certainly seems to be
it opens up one very dark reality about
donkey his personality and what he wants
to keep hidden about his past shortly
after that Shrek the third clip I played
earlier to get ourselves these lines
where it seems like donkey admits to his
tragic origin story when you are clearly
not aware of the underpants let's just
say some things are better left unsaid
and leave it at that what first appears
to be a joke about donkeys wearing
underwear according to this theory
actually becomes donkey not wanting to
address the horrific way he became a
donkey in the first place some things
are better left unsaid he doesn't want
to talk about his trauma which is
totally fine until you consider the
timeline of events
Pinocchio story begins with him as a
lifeless toy let's call this stage one
he then becomes a living toy which we'll
call stage 2 stage 3 is when it becomes
a partial donkey living toy for a while
before finally entering stage 4 at the
end of the movie when he's turned into a
fully grown human boy now throughout the
Shrek movies Pinocchio appears
exclusively in his stage 2 living toy
form meaning the events depicted in
Shrek occur after Pinocchio comes to
life but before he's sent off to
Pleasure Island and becomes a weird
partial donkey creature so in the Shrek
films Pinocchio has no idea that
Pleasure Island even exists but donkey
does he's already been there in fact we
know that he managed to escape like we
see in that Alexandre clip
might your name be Alexander so you
can't all take it back we know donkey
has turned but hasn't gone full donkey
yet like all the other kids that are
being shipped off to the Salt Mines
meaning that he managed to escape before
that happened the long and short of what
I'm saying here is that donkey knows
full well that the evil Pleasure Island
scheme of kidnapping boys and selling
them as donkeys into the salt mines is
in full swing
even as the events of Shrek are taking
place the criminals running the Pleasure
Island scheme are very careful not to
ship off any boys turned donkeys off the
island till they can no longer talk
because donkeys who can talk could
feasibly tell people on the mainland
about their criminal enterprise and shut
the whole thing down but here we have
ourselves donkey the lone fairytale
creature who could end all the suffering
of so many boys but does donkey step up
to the challenge of being a hero does he
tell anyone about the ongoing horrors of
Pleasure Island does he do anything to
stop these atrocities let's just say
some things are better left unsaid and
leave it at that
he does not said he just follows Shrek
around for a few movies living it up
banging dragons in the morning I'm
making waffles he was turned into a
donkey because presumably he was a bad
kid it seems like he hasn't improved
with age orphaned boys are getting
kidnapped and sold off by the boatload
and donkey is letting it happen
does this make donkey a complete ass I
don't know but in the end there's
definitely blood on donkeys hands or I
suppose hooves but hey that's just a
theory
Oh film theory and if you want to see
more Shrek I suggest you watch our other
video on Shrek's deadly farts there is
an actual scientific explanation for why
his farts are so dangerous and we go
into that on the video to the left or
you know what do me a favor and check
out that channel I mentioned earlier
Schaefer Ellis productions his analyses
of classic animated movies coming from
Disney and Pixar he's incredibly
insightful in his observations and it's
just funny to boot it's not the best but
it's my favorite which is a pretty
impressive feat considering how generic
the story is
I first discovered him through his
videos on Trek and I've been watching
him ever since but I don't think anyone
ever takes a look at it and says oh yeah
now that's one of the greatest sequels
in cinematic history why am i Luigi he's
doing great work out there he's only got
500,000 subscribers go out show him some
love give him some of that valuable
watch time that YouTube cherishes so
much and tell a mad mad Sencha and
shaffer list if at some point you wanna
do something together let me know I
would love to talk to you about that
you're doing great work out there man
hopefully this gets you a bit more
attention so anyway that's it for today
I need to start working on some scary
theories for October I'll see you then
[Music]